c'est bien une prostate géante qui a été
installé sur le parvis de la clinique
des franciscaines à versailles en ce
mois de novembre dédié au cancer
masculin
le public est invité à s'informer sur
les pathologies de cette glande méconnus
comme la dénomme de prostate
ça leur permet de bien comprendre que
quand il ya un flux rynair qui doit
passer là dans un canal qui est comme ça
complètement bouché et va avoir du mal à
s'écouler
donc je rappelle juste la dncg c'est une
augmentation du volume de la glande
sans parler de cancer le cancer est lui
situé sur la partie périphérique de
l'organe
il est dépisté à l'aide d'un toucher
rectal et sur une évaluation de
l'évolution du taux de psa antigène
spécifique de la prostate il se fait à
l'aide d'une prise de sang
si ces deux mesures présentent des
anomalies on réalise une irm puis des
biopsies avant de réfléchir à un
traitement des traitements justement
expliqué lors de conférences pour cette
journée spéciale
donc il ya quatre possibilités la
première c'est de ne rien faire parce
que l'on sa prostate peut être parfois
considéré comme un vieillissement normal
de la prostate la deuxième c'est la
curiethérapie donc là ça consiste à
mettre des implants radioactifs
directement prostate le troisième c'est
la radiothérapie externe et le dernier
ces échanges on trouve peu
d'informations dans les journaux donc
j'en permet d'avoir une idée de au moins
poser quelques questions on y avoir des
réponses plus le cancer et des saules et
au mieux et se guérit le dépistage est
recommandée dès l'âge de 50 ans passé 80
ans les hommes 80 % de risques de
présenter des cellules tumorales
alors pour poursuivre la sensibilisation
le prostate aux formes un prochain arrêt
vendredi 8 novembre à massy